und das bringt jetzt auch und die
verbrennen jetzt natürlich also das ist
ganz normaler ergonomische algorithmus
dass tiere verbrennen wenn sie mich
verarschen diese sterben nicht
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge des minecraft guides
heute ein paar kuriose fakten als sonst
mal sonst waren es einmal so
spielerische dinge diesmal zwar auch und
zwar die dritte sache ist eine spiel ein
spielerisches teil sag ich mal einfach
eine spielerische information sage ich
mal
allerdings auch noch so ein paar
grundlegende sachen die einfach so ein
bisschen ich sag mal es sind mehrere fun
fact sollte drin als wenn man drei
normale sachen und einen fun fact heute
sind aber ein bisschen mehr also die
erste sache ist eigentlich ganz simpel
und zwar gibt es im kompletten spiel
weniger kürbisse also von diesen hier
als diamant ärzte also wenn ich jetzt
zum beispiel einfach war hier so rum
gucke ich sehe keinen einzigen kürbis
als wenn ich hier so rum kobler das
medium obwohl davon auch gewitter
auftreten
jetzt gar keine kürbis allerdings sind
hier überall wie zb hierhin geschafft
hier sind mehrere höhlen einfach und da
können ja immer mal so überall diamanten
drin vorkommen und dass man erst mal gar
nicht so vermutet weil man wirklich
selten diamanten findet und meistens
wenn man dann nach diamanten findet die
die von euch minecraft noch so spielen
ich mach dass er nicht mehr
die werden das wahrscheinlich kennen das
man meistens kürbisse vor diamanten
findet aber eigentlich sind die kürbisse
viel seltener als diamanten weil sie
einfach viel seltener auftreten
so kommen wir zur zweiten sache die ich
euch auch zeigen wollte und zwar kennt
ihr alle diese schilder da kommen jetzt
einfach mal hin schreiben
hallo ich bin luca so oder beschreiben
man kann er da auch so zu zeichnen
machen wie zum beispiel so was hier das
passt natürlich dann immer ich kann das
hier normal machen oder noch mal oder
auch mit ihm gleich zeichen oder so das
passt natürlich immer perfekt auf diesem
schild länge hinaus allerdings wenn man
dieses zeichen macht diese welle
das geht über das schild hinaus ich weiß
nicht warum es ist zurzeit noch ein
fehler aber man kann damit auf jeden
fall über das schild hinaus schreiben
wenn wir das ganze jetzt mal hier so uns
anschauen dann seht ihr schon das geht
dann auch auf andere schilder über bzw
wenn ich das mache dann geht es auch
über diesem block hinaus diese moment
diese zahlen von hinten sieht man das
ganze nicht man sich das ganze nur von
vorne als wenn ich ihre lange ehe seht
ihr schon da tauchen diese zeichen auf
also die gehen wirklich da geht immer
ein zeichen über diese länge hinaus
dürfte eigentlich nicht sein auf jeder
seite müsste eigentlich ein zeichen
weniger sein wie schon gesagt bei allen
möglichen anderen zeichen ist dies
wiederum nicht der fall egal war was ich
hier schreibe ich kann man hier so
beschreiben alles das ist alles wirklich
noch im rahmen allerdings geht dieses
zeichen einfach darüber hinaus und das
ist echt das ist richtig traurig das
macht mich richtig raus das ist
unglaublich so kommen wir nun auch schon
zum dritten akt ich finde es immer so
komisch wenn man so sagt fags zu dritten
informationen die ich euch heute geben
möchte über das spiel und zwar haben
sich jetzt bestimmt schon einige gefragt
hey da steht kein titel warum ist da
keine kämmerin höhe april april hieß
und zwar als aprilscherz aber eigentlich
habe ich nur vergessen und dass man sich
als ausrede aber relativ egal ist und
zwar kennen das bestimmt schon einige
allerdings gibt es immer noch leute die
ich kenne die einfach so sagen hey wie
das geht und zwar wenn mancher schafe
wenn man schweine hat man die einfach
mal an ich könnte einfach mal hier feuer
hinsetzen dann brennt das schaf schwein
so und das brennt jetzt auch und die
verbrennen jetzt natürlich also das ist
ein ganz normaler ergonomische
algorithmus dass tiere verbrennen wenn
sie
mich verarschen sterben nicht ja der
erst jetzt tot zum beispiel und zwar
droppen dieser tiere
wenn sie sterben dann keine rohes
schweinefleisch sondern gebratenes
schweinefleisch ist eine sehr gute
variante wenn man zum beispiel eine
monster falle baut dann kann man die
ganzen mops die dort oben spawn
runterfallen lassen weil sie zeigt dass
manche runterfahren lassen und dann
irgendwie hier unten so rein plumpsen
und da drin ist dann zum beispiel so
wenig source and never say never recken
durchgängig brennen und dann fallen die
ganzen tiere dar ein und verbrennen dann
quasi beziehungsweise fahren durch eine
lava bande das kann man ja somit leiter
machen das geht fallen dadurch brennen
und kommen dann in den raum verbrennen
und dann wird das alles zu
schweinefleisch das ganze schweine
vielleicht wieder runter gespielt das
kann man alles bauen habe ich damals
selber so gebaut um einen minecraft
zeiten war der sonne
jedenfalls wenn die tiere verbrannt
beziehungsweise schweine dann bekommt
ihr direkt gebraten ist und ich weiß
nicht ob das gleiche bei queen der
verletzter können wir jetzt mal ganz
direkt hier einfach so einen test machen
denn die für überhaupt baku war so
zackig schmeißen
ein live experiment experiment nicht
experimentell und nutzlos schauen uns
das mal an
und tötete wir bekommen auch schon steak
also gebratenes fleisch so und dann
kommen wir nun auch schon zum fun fake
fur diese folge bzw jetzt schon zum ende
tut mir leid tut mir leider leicht und
zwar ist es dass die eier hinzugefügt
wurden nachdem ein spieler ist gefordert
hatte und bot der spieler dann gesagt
wenn du das wirklich hinzufügt dann
würde er einen usb stick essen das film
und dem o'young team senden und das hat
deutschland auch hinzugefügt und das
video hat er jetzt irgendwo hat er
allerdings nicht veröffentlicht bzw
gleiches veröffentlicht hat vielleicht
wisst ihr was darüber könnt ihr dann
einfach in die kommentare schreiben zwar
dieser einfach dass man hühner quasi so
spawnen muss bz es gibt ja auch joppich
spawn gibt es kinder sbornaja ich weiß
es nicht jedenfalls wurde das hier
hinzugefügt mit diesen ganzen eierwerfen
nachdem das wirklich ein spieler gesagt
hey notch wenn du das hinzufügt mit den
eiern dass man die werfen kann und dass
man damit auch spieler treffen kann und
dass man damit mops treffen kann und
auch damit so alt
diese kleinen teile hier ist man kann
diese kleinen mädchen dann würde ich
meinen usb stick essen und dir das film
und jeder ständen und das hat man schon
auch gemacht also das heißt dann wieder
da steht dann wirklich wieder dafür dass
das komplette mojang team echten
ganztägiges team ist dass sie alles nur
spaß machen und nicht unbedingt aus
kommerziellen gründen und meine lieben
freunde ich würd sagen das war's mit
minecraft guide folge vier sind wir
mittlerweile schon wie man diese serie
kommt sehr gut an also wie immer wenn es
euch gefallen hat einfach einen daumen
hoch geben
schaffen wir eventuell könnten
entscheiden 1004 für den ersten 41 01
4000 hier geschaffen das ist mir das
klar und schreibt mir weiterhin fact in
die kommentare die ich eventuell der
breiten öffentlichkeit präsentieren soll
weil ihr die zwar kennt allerdings die
breite öffentlichkeit noch nicht und
dann würde ich erst mal sagen und
wunderschönen ostermontag ich weiß nicht
ob heute abend noch die unkomplizierte
kommt weil sie mir bisher noch nicht
online
wir müssen einfach gucken sonst habt ihr
jetzt etwa den minecraft guide für heute
und dann sehen wir beim nächsten mal